Now that we have our ABO MRNA complete, what's next?
>> Well the next step is to bring that MRNA copy out of
the nucleus and into the cytoplasm where it can be translated into protein.
>> Okay, going back to the cake analogy we now have a recipe copied
in the kitchen, we're ready to cook but. What are the ingredients to a protein?
>> Right, I guess you know the ingredients for food and now you know
the ingredients for DNA there are ingredients
for proteins and they're called amino acids.
Amino acids are the basic building blocks of proteins, unlike
DNA which only has four ingredients. Proteins are made up
of amino acids, 20 different kinds of them. Each of
these amino acids, has its own name, its own chemical structure.
And they can be strung together in a row, in
a sequence just like our DNA letters could. Now, each amino
acid has its own name and its own abbreviation. We
have three letter abbreviations and one letter abbreviations. We're going to
go back and forth using them, so try
to familiarize yourself with both. But if you
ever get stuck, you're one Google search away
from trying to remember exactly what you need.
>> That's a lot of ingredients. So, there's four in a DNA, and then there's 20
that make up the proteins. But how do
those four DNA ingredients correspond to the amino acids.
>> That is a really good question and it's what we're about to explore.